and all it took was two networks to pick
up
lunch that they made i'm gonna bring my
my espresso cappuccino machine on a cart
around like tuesday takeout i mean i
paid 16 bucks
no i didn't but he did
but it's a really bizarre
investment
from california then right we're on our
stage
chester valley a couple of depots on the
lows and uh there's
my brother look at that six panel votes
we went from 450 kids to 40.
unicode
thank you
okay
so
it might just be very loose you know
thank you
so
so
okay
get it
so
okay
so
so
so
[Music]
i'm feeling more relaxed
every day and i wonder if he's buying
time and like i mean north carolina yeah
that's the untold story is that the
is
is
is
so outspoken
i do love yeah
yes
right
you had to wear
yesterday
again
is
good morning everyone thank you for
being here i have a special guest with
us today
uh the distinguished chair of the energy
and commerce committee
mr frank pallone i asked him to join us
because of the discussions that we are
and gate have been engaged in about how
we go forward
the simple fact is and has always been
that unless we crush the virus
we're not going to be able to open our
economy or our schools
or our society safely
since march 4th we had our first
coronavirus bill
testing testing testing has been
a focal point of addressing crushing the
virus
it has been in the legislation but it
has not been
a priority for this administration
and so in our bill that we put forth our
heroes act
that honors our heroes our state and
local folks who are health care workers
first responders
sanitation transportation food workers
who are on the front line our teachers
our teachers our teachers
that on the front line they risk their
lives to save all their lives
and now they may lose their jobs in
order to protect
them and our children and our our
country
we have to do what we do in the in the
heroes act which is crush the virus
and it's not just about having the
language as we have over and over
acting in good will that the
administration would
listen to the scientists when it came to
testing tracing
treatment mask wearing separation
ventilation sanitation did i say that
instead this bill heroes
lays out the plan and it is a plan that
the energy and commerce
put to committee under the leadership of
frank colon
put together based on science
science science and what we have to do
to crush the virus
and why the administration decides to
ignore science
has contempt for science the death toll
rises since we passed our bill
nearly five months ago
over a hundred thousand more people have
died millions more have been infected
because they want to ignore science and
because they disdain governance
they don't want to say obey science that
would say now you
are required to do this or that we're on
a path
that we should never never have been on
at this point
so when the administration when the
president did his strange
tweet that said we're walking away from
the negotiations
it was like what we've all been working
very hard
to find our common ground to agree on
language
so that we have an understanding of what
the legislation will do
we still haven't heard back on the score
of the amen
uh the language for testing tracing
treating
so that means that they just want money
for the president to spend on who knows
what
who's showing up at one of his golf
clubs or something that he's gonna go
buy their stuff
but this is a plan a strategic plan that
mr
pallone will describe and that
scientists
have helped put together and support
so when the president did his tweet the
one that said
uh that um he was walking away
i think he surprised a lot of people i
don't want to go into who they are right
now
but it was a disservice to the
discussion that we were having
in good faith when he walked away from
the discussion he walked away from our
children
he walked away from how we can open up
our schools virtually act
virtually actually or in hybrid form how
we can
educate our children he walked away from
poor children in our country
in terms of the child tax credit and the
child dependent child
credit and uh other
initiatives that help the forced
children in our country
he walked away uh from what we were
trying to do
uh to put money in the pockets of the
american people
food on the table rent so they're not
evicted
all of it coronavirus centric all of it
corona virus centric
not addressing any larger issue corona
virus centric
he walked away from our heroes he said
to those health care workers
police and fires i said before teachers
teachers teachers
transportation sanitation food workers
and the rest
we just don't care you just don't matter
this is really appalling the list goes
on and on and of course
he walked away from safety in the
workplace he walked about
uh the lives the livelihood and the life
of our democracy in so many ways so here
we are
uh now
planting staking out the territory
so that the people will know there is a
plan
and the plan isn't for the president to
say that he's a perfect physical
specimen did he say specimen maybe i
could agree with that
and and young he said he was young that
his
disassociation from reality
would be funny if it weren't so deadly
and his people these enablers around who
are enabling death
the death toll to rise we can we have to
shed a bright light
on what has been possible for months
that they chose to ignore because of
their contempt for congress
and their disdain for governance and so
that's why
if there's one thing that has to be in
this bill that he has never
made as a priority it's
crushing the virus instead of the denial
delay distortion
lack of reality that the president has
all long
brought to this let's not it be
anecdotal let it be scientific
in that regard i'm very proud to be with
frank pallone this morning he has worked
on this issue he knows these
health issues backward forward over the
years
so he can place this in the context
of public health of science
about reaching as many people as
possible
and let me just close by saying this
when the president did his tweet
he said i want the senate to spend full
time
fully focused on the nomination
so i'm not going to have them be doing
anything
on stopping the spread of the viruses is
essentially what that is
full focus on the nomination why
so that somebody can be in there on time
for the oral arguments on november 10th
to overturn the affordable care act
to overturn the affordable care act this
in the time of a pandemic
the president going to court and
overturning the affordable care act
overturning the pre-existing condition
benefit
that 150 million families in america
depend upon overturning the fact that
tens of millions more people
have access to health care overturning
the preventive and essential benefits
package overturning
uh so many aspects of the affordable
care act
uh including if you have a senior in
your family who is um
on long-term care much of it paid for
by medicaid
and then to not misrepresent the truth
he has a plan for that benefit
well we haven't seen it in four years
we haven't seen it in four years no
family in america can afford
unlimited expenses that would come
with not having the pre-existing
condition benefit and
the other provision in the bill
that removes the insurance company
caps of what they would spend on a
person
so lives are at stake health is in the
balance
this is deadly serious so let's take
a serious not a skinny not an emaciated
but a serious appropriate approach to
crushing the virus
and then talk about some of the other
good things that would flow from that
with that again i'm proud to
uh present the chairman of the way the
energy and commerce committee a person
who's
had spent decades on these issues and
we're blessed that he would have his
leadership at this time
uh to address this issue mr palump
thank you thank you madam speaker let me
just
you're not going to be able to open the
economy you're not going to be able to
recover the economy
unless you crush the virus and also your
emphasis that this is our responsibility
that this is the government's
responsibility this is washington's
responsibility
to do something about this and the
speaker never hesitates i mean i haven't
been
part of the negotiations but whenever
she talks to us
i know that when the president raises
one issue he is well she says well what
about the virus what about the testing
what are you going to do about that and
so i just want to thank you for really
prioritizing and constantly
bringing it up it's hard for me to
believe that it's now october
and it's 10 months into this pandemic
and the trump administration still
doesn't have a national
testing tracing surveillance and
containment plan
uh in place we've been asking for this
from the very beginning
worse yet they can't even effectively
test or trace or contain the cova within
the confines of the white house
i mean i heard this morning that he's
back in the oval office potentially
spreading this
to the people that work for him in the
white house as they
may be spreading it to to to washington
and others
in fact one of the concerns that i have
is in my home state of new jersey you
probably know that
new jersey's done a very good job in the
last few months
of actually containing the virus but the
president came and had a fundraiser at
bedminster on his golf course you
mentioned his golf course
and now we the governor is trying to
contact trace
the people that were there to see if
they're spreading it and actually
raising their numbers in new jersey
i mean it is just insane what he does he
refuses
uh to to to acknowledge that we're not
going to be able to crush this virus
unless we have some kind of a national
plan to deal with this
and the state is paying for that well
that's the other thing uh the state you
know received
we did have money in the cares act again
thanks to the speaker and all of all of
us in the congress that voted for it
but that money is running out uh we only
had about half of what we need
and most of that has already been spent
so the speaker is right look
now i'm going to talk a little bit about
what's in the heroes act and the updated
uh heroes act that we passed like last
week to address this
but i just have to emphasize again that
the president
in cutting off the negotiations and
refusing to talk about this
is making the possibility of this
national plan less and less
likely every day he just doesn't want to
do it
now what we in terms of the testing and
the contact tracing i think you know
that we have 75 billion dollars in
funding
to support the testing the contact
tracing
and the surveillance but just as
important as the money
is the fact that we have uh we we state
not only that we should have a national
plan but we have we talk about clear
benchmarks and time loans
and a strategy to achieve
the level of testing that is necessary
right now there's only about
900 000 tests being done per day around
the country
and health experts that have testified
before our committee say you need
4 million a minimum per day so that's
less than 25 percent if you will of
what's absolutely necessary
so when anybody tells you we're doing
enough testing or the president says
anybody can be tested
it is simply not true we are not doing
enough
testing uh and the bottom line is
that it's also a question of the
national government setting guidelines
why do you think the states
different states use different types of
tests and a lot of times the tests don't
work
they scramble for this for the for the
things they use for the testing
uh different states don't know what to
do about the schools and when they
should open or what they need to
to open this should be all done on a
national level and this is done in a lot
of other countries on the national level
and it's not being done here because the
president doesn't want to have
a national plan now we have also as
democrats
stressed vaccines the president only
wants until recently only wanted to talk
about vaccines
but we also in the updated heroes act
address the vaccines very effectively
we create a national vaccine plan we
provide 28 billion dollars in additional
funds to develop
manufacture and promote access to
vaccines
and therapeutics of those funds seven
billion dollars go to
conducting activities to expand and
improve vaccine distribution
a lot of that actually will go to the
states which we said needed for them to
continue
and also a billion dollars goes to
evidence-based public
awareness campaign the states have been
asked by
october 16th which i believe is next
week to put together
individual plans for vaccine
distribution
and we want it to be as equitable as
possible but just like they need the
money for testing
they also need the money for the
vaccines if they're going to be able to
have
an effective plan and the hero is hacked
as
has that but if it's not passed and the
president doesn't address it and doesn't
go back to the negotiating table
it's going to be very hard for the
states to actually develop those vaccine
plans that that they have to put forward
uh by next week now all we've heard from
the president
until recently was vaccine vaccine right
and it was obvious that he wanted to
approve this vaccine
by election day whether or not it was
going to be effective thank god
and i i mean that thank god that the fda
went ahead
and issued these new guidelines that
that make it
clear that we have to have an additional
two months from when the vaccine has
been finally developed
to actually test it and make sure we
don't have adverse events
adverse effects i always say you know
it's like when you go to the hospital
and they say oh the operation was
successful but the patient died
we don't need a vaccine that may not be
effective
but we also don't need a vaccine that's
actually going to have so many adverse
events
uh that you know people die from the
effect of the vaccine
so the bottom line is now at least we
have the fda out there with the
guidelines
but we're still concerned that he may
override the fda
and just go ahead and say well this is a
vaccine anyway it's okay you don't need
the fda's approval
and we want to stress that that should
not happen now the final thing
is within the last 24 hours madam
speaker
with regeneron it's almost as if well i
tried the uh you know the silver bullet
with the vaccine but now
i don't have that anymore so now i'll
move to regeneron which the experimental
drug
that he was treated with and now he's he
issued a video i guess in the last 24
hours saying
well i'm going to have this thing
approved by the fda under emergency use
and i'm going to have it distributed and
manufactured and everybody's going to
have it again
well again language is saying i'm going
to override the fda i'm going to
override the science i know what works
needless to say we know we don't know if
it works
and we have no reason to believe that
it's going to be available i think they
said
the company that produces it that they
have 50 000 the availability to treat 50
000 people
more than 50 000 people uh got the virus
yesterday
right and almost a thousand died
yesterday
so what are you talking about mr
president once again you're ignoring the
science
you're politicizing the issue stop stop
this
help us get the heroes act
the heroes act has the tools and the
resources necessary to crush the virus
we're not going to wish this away we
have to rise to the challenge
the speaker has risen to the challenge
the president has not
pleased mr president come back to the
negotiating table let's get these
critical testing
and vaccine provisions signed into law
so we can crush
the virus and do the responsible thing
as our speaker said to the american
people
and thank you again madam speaker thank
you mr chairman thank you mr chairman
on that score of the language because
again we have put resources for testing
again and again and again but left to
their own devices
they did not have a plan except to use
it
almost in a political way and this is a
plan to do it in a scientific way
i also want to make the point that is
very important to our plan
is that we are recognizing that the uh
communities of color have been
disproportionately hit
by this uh by this virus
and that's why we need the testing
tracing treatment separation etc
uh address into those communities
and that's part of what this plan will
do as well
and just to before take questions to say
in every part of the bill whether he's
talking about
uh let the states go bankrupt i'm not
doing any blue states or any of that
many of those employees are people of
color
many of them serve people of color their
rejection of doing this
right is harmful to people of color
and how they want to spend their money
on the schools
is harmful to children of color and so
this
this is i people say to me you're not
going to be able to correct
every ill in society in this bill
i said that's true this is coronavirus
centric
but i'm not going to make matters worse
and uh solidify the disparity that we
see
as this virus continues to spread
when i talked to the administration most
recently last evening
i said you still haven't
given us a response to the language
after all this time
they admitted that questions on this
subject
just just get better your office has
indicated that you've talked to the
secretary
about a stand-alone bill to help the
airlines
can you update us on that progress and
to that end with the entire economy
hurting why do the airlines deserve
special treatment
well let me just stay with this subject
and i'll come back to you gary
let me just say this this issue
and now the president we pray for his
health his recovery his family
34 people in the white house
infected by this and still and still
not an acceptance of what needs to be
done
i think that the public needs to know
the health
condition of the president there's one
question that he refuses they refuse to
answer
when was before he got the virus
and admitted to it when was his last
negative test when was his last
negative test to make a judgment about
the actions that were taken
after that members of the press ask the
question it gets deflected
but it is a very important question for
our country
because now the president is saying that
he probably got this
from the gold star families can you
believe that he would say such a thing
he probably got this from the gold star
families so let us see a date a
time when you last tested
negative before you admitted
uh to this virus on the subject
of how we crush the virus and how we go
forward are there any questions for our
gym yes sir
i just want to ask about the
negotiations about this subject and and
it's related
i will come back to it because this is
central to the negotiations
it's no use saying we're going to give
the administration more money to do
whatever they want with it
unless we get to the heart of the matter
and crush this
yes ma'am on this topic um it's clear
that the issue is as much about
the president pulling away from the
negotiations but also the republicans in
the senate
who have uh shown some concern about
spending more money
yet at the same time we saw some some
republican senators coming out and
saying they thought it was a mistake to
walk away from the negotiations
are you in any way talking to leader
mcconnell
to any of these republican senators who
perhaps could um weigh in on this in a
way that would
help help bring some resolution here
okay so you're not talking about this
subject either
anybody want to talk about what
we all say we're talking about what are
we
are these what we want to talk about
is the fact that we have not and and
to your point about the republican
senators their accomplices
uh to what the pres the president is
doing in terms of uh
ignoring the science that could save
lives
so that is the point of this and it is
central to the negotiations
and there's no way that we can just say
let's just
write some text and give it to the
president so we can give it out any way
he wants
when he's not getting to the heart of
the matter now you had that first
question that
since there uh seems to be uh
i don't know what about how you don't
understand
that this is we are where we are
because of that do you have any
questions about what mr
pallone is proposing if not i'll answer
garrett's question
yeah i mean garrett let me just be
really clear
i uh i have been very open to having a
single stand-alone bill
for the airlines or part of a bigger
bill
but there is no standalone bill without
a bigger bill
there is no bill because you you ask the
second question why should we do one not
the other
and so the the comment that i made to
the administration last night was
we're happy to review what that
standalone bill would look like
as part of a bigger bill if there is a
bigger bill but there is no stand
alone bill you would not move forward at
all on a standalone airline bill
if we don't have a guarantee that we're
going to be helping
our state and local employees that we're
not going to be able to crush the virus
that we're not going to be able to have
our children go to school safely
that we're not going to have safety in
the workplace that we're not going to
address
unemployment uh that we're not going to
have them
and some of these issues we have come to
some area of agreement
but some of them we have not but they
have walked away
from the whole package and that includes
17 million children in the country food
insecure
millions of their families on the verge
of eviction
on the verge of eviction and the
president says
well i'll do these three things well
that's not going to happen
it's not going to happen and i and i
take pride in the fact that
when the workers and the unions the
unions and the companies
did their press event last week they
said they advocated for a full
bill let's see who is
next on that you are at this i just want
to so last night
uh mnuchin said to you he's interested
in getting back to talking about a
longer
a larger bill but he would need the
president's buy-in
so you've been involved i don't i don't
i don't i would not put those
exact words in his mouth no so could you
tell us what the exactly
there were no exact words like that it
was what we were talking about a single
bill
a stand-alone bill and the uh
particulars within a singular bill
because they have some objection to what
we put
you know we had a um a uc
a unanimous consent request last week
that the republicans
rejected and so um
and the senate had their own version
which they even
rejected themselves the senate
republicans rejected themselves
so the question is what if there were to
be a standalone bill
what does that look like and the only
point about negotiations
is ain't going to be no standalone bill
unless there's a long-term a bigger bill
and it could be part of that
or it could be in addition to that
you've been involved now
off and on since july over this package
and and
actually since may since maybe
it's almost five months excuse me more
so so
could you just give us a sense i mean
the president pulled away mnuchin seems
eager to do something i mean give us
your prospects here
of where you think things are given your
talks with mnuchin
and the president and mcconnell's i
guess hesitancy to
or or disagreement about the larger
package could you just give us
what your prospects are at this moment
well i don't know what the prospects are
when we hear people saying i'm i'm young
and i'm a perfect perfect specimen
instead of addressing the fact
that what 50 000 people were
in fact reported to be infected
yesterday nearly a thousand people
died what are we talking about here
tomorrow
by the way tomorrow come here tomorrow
we're going to be talking about the 25th
amendment but not to take attention away
from the subject we have now
okay here's the thing we've been working
very hard
on language because if you don't have
the language you're just giving them a
blank check
to do what they have done which is to
ignore
crushing the virus and so we're saying
is
with all the trust that we had before
and let me use the word trust
trust trust with all the trust in the
world that they
the uh the argument will be so
compelling uh
to to open up our comm our economy and
our schools and the rest that they would
do
something but they didn't and now frank
for five months what will be five months
and a few days
for the 15th of may 15th of october
because
five months so the point is is that
early on we had lots of negotiations
they want to know our justification for
child care and
they want to know our justification for
earned income
tax credit because you know there's
fraud there right
okay you want to talk about fraud for
the poorest people in america getting an
earned income tax credit
uh while the president is paying
spending paying 750 dollars
for his taxes in a year that he did pay
taxes so
okay so getting back to your question
we've been working
on what the language would look like we
have our differences in numbers but it's
no use
um having just a numbers discussion
unless we know what that money is spent
on
otherwise we're just giving billions
hundreds of billions
more than a trillion two trillion
dollars to the president
uh to spend any way he wants but not
to address the issues at hand so the
um so so that's and that's why it was so
disappointing i said
i almost wondered if mr mnuchin even
knew the president was going to
do that i even wonder if mitch mcconnell
and
mccarthy knew that the president was
going to do that
uh you might want to ask them but the uh
fact is
is that uh in saying what he said forget
everything we're just focusing on
the supreme court nomination
to overturn the affordable care act uh
was so
undermining of all of the work there's a
lot of work a lot of staff
that goes into clarifying so we have
been understanding what the language
means making concessions here or there
or clarifications or
prioritizing in a different way it's
called
legislating it's called legislating
it's a foreign language to the white
house in many respects
but it is what we have to do to save
lives
and that's what we intend to do and i
was optimistic because why would you
engage in all these conversations
unless you were optimistic that
something could come of it
and we did move uh uh in some areas
but everything is not nothing is agreed
to until everything is agreed to
that's the way it always is
are you still optimistic that i'm
hopeful i'm hopeful because it has to be
done
as the president wants to wait until he
wins the election well that might be an
eternity
but if he wants to wait until after the
election uh then
uh that would be unfortunate because
more people will die more will be
infected
more kids will have uncertainty about
how they're learning
more uh kids will go without food uh
evictions will you know moratorium is a
nice thing but somebody's got to pay the
rent
at some point and again more people will
be fired
from our state and local government
which meets the needs of the american
people so
every day of delay is a problem
but again if they if they were not going
to
um again ossify the injustices
that that have become part of this in
terms of
of the um communities of color and just
people
just people who have a predisposition to
catching
uh such a virus yes chad thank you so
in your talks with the secretary excuse
me is that did you have anything you
wanted to add to any of that
no thank you
in your talk with secretary of duty do
you get the sense
that he is on the same page with the
president i mean you said
it seemed like there might have been the
situation that he didn't know that the
president was pulling out
thomas didn't know some republicans that
they have been like
what we've heard about some of the
proposals he's put forth
uh i i i believe he president probably
informed i don't know you'll have to ask
him
i asked him he said he knew i said you
knew he was going to tweet
you knew he was going to tweet that
after you have engaged
in months of negotiations with the
speaker of the house
article one the first branch of
government
with all the work that we have done
respectful of your point of view trying
to find
reconciliation and common ground
that the congress of the united states
would be treated
with disrespect by a tweet by the
president to say it's off
is that an appropriate notification
so that he could focus full time
on the nomination on the nomination
so this is not the way that happens but
again
we embrace the good there's a bad word
for that
and um and you know again it's not about
him
it's about people in america who are
susceptible to this
when he comes to your office or on the
phone he's not coming tomorrow he came
to the office last wednesday
don't worry about me don't worry about
me i get tested all the time because i
i i'm in conversation with the president
really i'll see you on the phone
but when you're on the horn with the
secretary you get the sense
that the president chief of staff
they're all on the same page and they
are
in fact representing the position of the
administration what their negotiating
position is
well i don't think that they are
secretary i don't know about the chief
of staff i mean i don't i don't even do
that
but the um secretary of the treasury
has been designated by the president to
engage in these negotiations
i have to trust of that that
but why would he why would he have these
conversations if he's not
speaking for the president of the united
states this is not a
an academic uh discussion if he's not
speaking for the president of the united
states there's no reason to have the
conversation i trust
that he is and i trust that he
wants to understand the differences so
we can try to find
common ground and hopefully we will
now let me just say another thing trust
trust is a word
that is so important in everything we do
and trust is important when we come to
the vaccines
we all want to pray for vaccine to come
soon
we want to have it not one day sooner
than it is safe and efficacious
but not one day later god willing it
will come
soon and that will be an answer for us
and maybe that's what makes the
administration act in
this uh the irresponsible way that they
do about
prevention because they are placing
so much on the vaccines thank god
for the scientists at the fda
who are scientists who are working 24
7 who created warped by the way that the
president launched onto who created warp
speed
and that they will their their work
their science their genius will be
rewarded
by having the appropriate
clinical trials so that what comes out
of it
is something that we can trust not
something politicized or a timetable
that is hastened
because of something else now frank do
you want to speak to the vaccine piece
again
well i think that what what we have in
the updated heroes act is trying to
address
a lot of the things that the speaker
mention in other words not only do we
have more money for actual
development of the vaccine but also for
the distribution
because as i mentioned actually states
by next week i think it's october 16th
is next week
are supposed to submit a plan but again
they don't have the money to do it
um and they don't and in my opinion a
lot of the guidance
they're getting isn't necessarily
helpful
and you could very easily have very uh
wide disparities from one state to the
next just like we did with the testing
for example
in new jersey uh we were gonna test or
the plan we submitted was a seven to
eight percent of the population
whereas uh the the white house said that
two percent was enough
actually you know two percent is totally
insufficient
and so again what we're saying that this
has to be nationalized not only do we
have to require the funding
as as the speaker said which is in the
heroes act and the updated version for
both the testing
the contact tracing and the vaccine but
there has to be a national plan for
doing all this
that plan has clearly uh failed
as far as the testing and the contact
tracing is concerned because they never
developed a national plan they left it
up to the states
now we're worried the same thing may
happen with the vaccine
in other words are states going to be
competing for the vaccine or
they have no real guidelines nationally
about how to distribute it
the speaker constantly talks about
equitable distribution right
it's not just a question of giving it
out to a few
select people it's a question of making
sure everyone gets it equitably and very
concerned about minority communities and
underserved communities
and how they're going to get it and the
president just keeps saying oh don't
worry you know everybody can have a test
everybody can get the vaccine or now you
know he moved on to
everybody can get uh you know the
treatment that he had with this
experimental
drug and and it just doesn't there's no
there's no national plan there's no
uniformity
and he is ignoring the science once
again i mean you know that he said that
with this latest uh drug that uh they
the company i guess within the last 24
hours
uh asked for emergency use authorization
but a lot of the scientists are you know
in the media saying we don't know
whether this thing works as nancy said
we don't even know
whether it's working on him we don't
even know when he you know they don't
give us the information about his own
his own case uh and it clearly is not
available
um to to any in any widespread way even
if it is approved and is effective
so you know i i feel like
look i i can't commend you enough madam
speaker because you keep
saying that the heart of what happens
with this negotiations has to be a
national plan for testing contract
tracing
equitable vaccine distribution uh and
and
and that's and and they're ignoring that
or they you know they they
act like oh well that doesn't matter
because uh you know that's not the main
focus of what we're trying to do to
crush the virus it has to be the main
focus
and that's what we're stressing thank
you and
i come back to the word trust because
when this vaccine
is put forth in a scientific way with
the appropriate clinical trials
and consent from the scientific advisory
committee that
that passes on these things that people
will have
trust in it and take the vaccine
because a vaccine is only as good as as
many people who will actually do it and
you see the numbers
are very split in our country so far as
to whether they would
avail themselves of it and that's why
this has to be
embraced for the scientific basis that
it has
not ignored because of the doubt as to
the timing of it that had something to
do with the election
rather than the scientific evidence that
it is safe
and effective yes sir you just said
do you think it's time to invoke the
25th amendment
i'll talk to you about that tomorrow
i'll talk to you about it tomorrow i'm
not talking about it today except to
tell you
if you want to talk about that i'll see
you tomorrow but you take me back to my
point mr president
when was the last time you had a
negative test
before you tested positive why is the
white house not
telling the country
that important fact about how this
uh spread into made a hot spot
of the of the white house thank you all
very much
thank you thank you
uh let me just say we've told the white
house we're at the table
we're at the table we want to continue
the conversation
we've made some progress we're changing
exchanging language
and then so we'll see how that how they
connect thank you thank you
oh
tomorrow